elliott laurana et chaabi ça j'avais
déjà fait un x fighters non non les
parcours super balèze en énigme ça va
être un petit peu plus aucun picsou
magazine disait vous êtes enfermé
pendant une heure dans une pièce et pour
en sortir vous êtes par réussir votre
mission
on a un miroir et on à la lettre de la
potasse qui dit je les supporte plus
j'ai envie de mourir
vous allez voir des indices qui vont
vous permettre en fait découvrir les
éditions pour voir gagner jusqu'à
l'ascension 12 ans et par peur ton truc
oui vous avez flipper
c'est bon j'arrête foot merda c'est bon
de sentir tout supplée c'est se sentir
attention ça est complètement taré cette
fille
j'ai pas envie trouver ici moi
gras brass
pourquoi ne répond pas
[Musique]
moyen bonne chance vous allez en avoir
besoin
[Musique]